presumptive democratic vice presidential
nominee kamala harris is taking aim at
president trump's questioning of
mail-in balloting in a tweet the
california senator takes note
of the president's requested ballot for
next week's florida primary
she writes quote donald trump votes by
mail but doesn't want you to
if it's good enough for him it's good
enough for us her remark comes as the
president appears dead set
on using a false and racist theory to go
after harris
at o'keefe reports ready to set go
at an event alongside joe biden
officially putting their names on the
democratic ticket
kamala harris brushed off questions
about the trump campaign's new
constitutional conspiracy
senator what do you make of president
trump and republicans attacks on
on you i'm signing this because i'm in
this race to win
and with that guy right there the
president and his campaign
are now publicly stoking a false and
racist theory circulating among his
supporters
that harris is ineligible to run for
vice president i heard it
today that she doesn't meet the
requirements
years of settled law say otherwise
harris's parents immigrated from jamaica
and india
and weren't citizens when she was born
in the united states
experts say her birth in oakland
california makes her a natural-born
citizen
which the constitution requires for the
president mr trump who says he opposes
the idea of birthright citizenship has
done this before to barack obama
why doesn't he show his birth
certificate on cbs this morning his
son-in-law did little to clarify the
president's position
he just said that he had no idea whether
that's right or wrong i don't see that
as promoting it but
look at the end of the day it's
something that's out there
you accept that she's a qualified
candidate i
personally have no reason to believe
she's not when asked the president said
he had no issue with a woman of color
running
no whatsoever you don't see her as you
no
none whatsoever and appearing at a
women's conference at the same time
harris acknowledged her history making
week joe biden
had the audacity to choose a black woman
to be his running mate
how incredible is that biden and harris
aren't expected to be seen again until
next week when they address the
democratic national convention
virtually from an event center in
biden's hometown of wilmington delaware
other high-profile speakers include the
clintons the obamas
and musical performances from john
legend and billy eilish
for cbs this morning saturday ed o'keefe
washington